How beautiful
Tagaya Kanaro - Zero - but I'm happy because I have a premonition that it will be delicious
[Music]
Uh,
I'm going to stay with you, because I
've never eaten while driving an artichoke so far
Ah, but I want to eat more pets
Narun, I can't help but be curious about it.
Shall we both try it?  I have succeeded in removing the sweetness and sharpening the
cream sauce
Shinorin acts directly on the taste receptors Yes,
it covers the part where you feel the sweetness of what you
did.
After that, when you eat another dish, the flex is gradually removed by chewing, and the
taste receptors start to function normally.
That's why
the combination of
Lee's Shigureni was emphasized
And when the judges finished eating their pizza  All the bending is removed from the bottom and
does not affect the subsequent examination.
Are you saying that there is no
family
aesthetic trajectory that
is swirling in your mouth?